>> BRAND NEW DETAILS SURROUNDING
THE WHIP GATE CONTROVERSY.
WE SAW PRESIDENT BIDEN FALSELY
ACCUSING AGENTS OF WHIPPING
HAITIAN MIGRANTS.
TURNS OUT IT WAS HORSE REINS.
BEFORE THE WHITE HOUSE HAD ALL
THE FACTS PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
VICE-PRESIDENT HARD WRIST
SLAMMING THE AGENTS INVOLVED.
>> TO SEE PEOPLE TREATED LIKE
THEY DID HORSES RUNNING OVER
PEOPLE BEING STRAPPED IT'S
OUTRAGEOUS.
I PROMISE THOSE PEOPLE WILL PAY
IT.
>> EVOKED IMAGES OF SOME OF THE
WORST MOMENTS OF OUR HISTORY
WHERE THAT KIND OF BEHAVIOR HAS
BEEN USED AGAINST THE DIGIT US
IN PEOPLE OF OUR COUNTRY USED
AGAINST SLAVELY.
>> HOMELAND SECURITY MAYORKAS
HIGHLIGHTED AND ARTICLE
INDICATING THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
MISCONSTRUED THE PHOTO.
INSTEAD OF CORRECTING THE RECORD
OR SPREADING THE WORD AROUND
MR. MAYORKAS WALKED INTO THE
WHITE HOUSE BRIEFING ROOM AND
SAID THIS INTO WE KNOW THAT
THOSE IMAGES PLAINLY CONJURED UP
THE WORST ELEMENTS OF OUR
ONGOING BATTLE AGAINST SYSTEMIC
RACISM.
>> YOU'VE BEEN THIS THAT
BRIEFING ROOM AND SEEN
SECRETARIES COME IN THERE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I THINK IT'S SHOCKING HOW
DISGUSTING IT IS.
WE KNEW FROM THE BEGINNING THAT
MOST PEOPLE DID IF YOU'VE GOT A
BRAIN THAT THE HORSE PATROL
USING REINS IN ORDER TO YOU HAVE
MANEUVER THE HORSE TO DO THEIR
JOB AND THEY GOT SMEARED.
THEY GOT PUT ON DESK DUTY AND
FACING 14 DAY SUSPENSION WITHOUT
PAY FOR SOME SORT OF
ADMINISTRATIVE ISSUE BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T WANT TO BE
EMBARRASSED.
IF I WERE THE PRESIDENT I WOULD
CALL MAYORKAS AND SAY EXCUSE ME
YOU HAVE THIS EMAIL AND YOU LET
US WALK AROUND AND SAY THIS OR
IS IT WORSE THAN THAT?
DID THEY KNOW HAND DECIDE IT DO
IT ANYWAY AND LET THESE GUYS
TWIST IN THE WIND.
BILL GAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY TWO DAYS TO
RESPOND TO MEDIA INQUIRY AND
THEY NEVER RESPONDED UNTIL
AFTERWARDS AND THEN TRIED TO
CLEAN IT UP.
THAT'S NOW HOW THIS WORKS.
THESE PUCK INFORMATION OFFICERS,
I STRESS PUBLIC FOR A REASON YOU
GET PAID BY THE TAXPAYER.
YOUR JOB IS TO RESPOND TO THE
PRESS EVEN TO SAY I HAVE NO
COMMENT OR I'M NOT TABLE TO TALK
ABOUT THIS, YOU COULD SAY
ANYTHING WANT BUT TO NOT CALL IS
NOT RIGHT AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION DOES THIS
CONSTANTLY ACROSS THE BOARD AND
BILL AND OUR REPORTERS WHO CALL
AND TRY TO GET ANSWERS DESERVE
BETTER BUT THESE HORSE A TROES
THAT GOT PUT OFF THE JOB AND HOW
MANY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS CAME
ACROSS DURING THAT TIME BECAUSE
OF THIS?
I THINK THE PRESIDENT OWES THESE
HORSE PATROL AN APOLOGY MANY HE
SHOULD GO TO THE BORDER AN VISIT
THEM OR INVITE THEM TO THE WITT
AND APOLOGIZE ON CAMERA.
IF THE REPUBLICANS TAKE OVER IN
JANUARY HE WILL BE FOLLOWUP AND
HE WILL HAVE TO ANSWER FOR IT
UNDERSTANDS OATH INTO GREG
YOU'RE NODDING THERE.
>> I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING.
I APOLOGIZE TO MOW LARRY AND
CURLY BUT THIS GUY IS A STOOGE.
HE'S A BE TEMPORARY.
HE HUNG HIS EMPLOYEES OUT TO DRY
FOR MINIMAL POLITICAL GAIN.
DO YOU REMEMBER HOW THE PRESS
ACTED?
IT WAS AN OPPORTUNE STICK HATE
CRIME HOAX.
IT WAS INCENDIARY.
EVERYBODY WHO TALKED ABOUT THIS
WAS SO EMOTIONALLY INVESTED IN
IT THEY DIDN'T WANT TO KNOW THE
TRUTH AND WE WERE REALLY GOOD.
I THOUGHT WE WERE GOING LET'S
WAIT.
NOBODY ELSE DID.
IF YOU WORK UNDER MAYORKAS CAN
YOU NOT TRUST HIM AGAIN.
HE'S A RAT.
HE WILL SELL OUT HIS
GRANDMOTHER.
IF HE HAD SELF RESPECT HE WOULD
RESIGN BUT HE HAS LESS THAN
TIMES SQUARE ELMO.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
I THINK THE THING IS THE WORST
THING ABOUT IT IS WE WERE HERE,
WE WERE RIGHT, AND NOBODY GAVE A
DAMN.
THOSE DIES WERE NOT EXONERATED.
WERE THEY SMEARED.
>> HOW DID THEY GET THEIR
REPUTATION BACK JUDGE?
WHAT WOULD BE THE RECOMMENDATION
YOU WOULD HAVE?
>> WHO WAS IT THE LABOR
SECRETARY WHO ASKED THAT
QUESTION AFTER HE PUT IN HOW DO
I GET MY REPUTATION BACK.
YOU DON'T GET IT BACK.
IF YOU WORK IN AN ADMINISTRATION
WHERE THIS IS TOLERATED WHERE IT
GOES RIGHT TO THE TOP WHERE
BEFORE KNOWING WHAT ANY OF THE
FACTS ARE THE PRESIDENT COMES
OUT AND TALKS ABOUT HORSES
RUNNING OVER PEOPLE AND WHEN
YOU'VE GOT THIS GUY MAYORKAS
SAYING IT CONJURES UP THE WORST
IMAGES OF OUR SYSTEMIC RACISM
YOU REALIZE THERE'S NO WAY FOR
THE MEN ON HORSES WHOSE JOB BY
THE WAY IT IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE BORDER IS PROTECTED, WHILE
THEY ARE ON THEIR HORSES WITH A
HORSE PROVIDED BY BORDER PATROL
AND THE REINS AS WELL?
I MEAN THEY HAVE CERTAIN THINGS
THAT THEY'RE REQUIRED TO DO BUT
THE SCARY PART IS IT'S ALL ABOUT
IDEOLOGY.
IT'S NOT ABOUT FACTS ANYMORE.
IT'S ABOUT WHETHER IT'S IN
SCHOOLS.
IT'S ABOUT RACE.
WHETHER IT'S ABOUT THE BORDER,
EVERYTHING IS WE'VE GOT WHITE
SUPREMACIST THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
IN THE COUNTRY AND THEN SAID
THOSE NUMBERS ARE INFLATED.
IT'S AN AGENDA THEY HAVE THAT IS
TOTALLY SEPARATE FROM THE TRUTH
AND REALITY AND THAT'S WHY
PEOPLE DON'T TRUST POLITICS
ANYMORE.
THEY CAN'T.
WHEN THEY SEE THIS THEY CANNOT.
>> PRIMETIME.
>> THERE ARE TWO TYPES OF PEOPLE
IN WASHINGTON.
THERE ARE THE LIARS AND THEN
THERE ARE THE IDIOTS BUT IN
ORDER TO GET AHEAD IN WASHINGTON
SUCCESSFULLY YOU HAVE TO BE A
LYING IDIOT.
THAT'S WHAT MAYORKAS IS.
MAYORKAS KNEW THOSE GUYS WERE
INNOCENT.
HE WENT OUT AND LIED ABOUT IT
AND DIDN'T TELL HIS BOSS BIDEN
THEY WERE INNOCENT.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND HOST IMPORTANT THING AS
AN EMPLOYEE IS TO MAKE YOUR BOSS
NOT LOOK FOOLISH.
HE MADE BIDEN LOOK VERY FOOLISH.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THE HOAX WAS
COMING AND HE HAD TO MAN UP AND
STOP THE HOAX AND HE JUST LET IT
PASS SO THEN EVERYBODY LOOKED
BAD.
INNOCENT GUYS GOT SMEARED.
REMEMBER THIS IS THE SAME GUY
THAT GAVE US THE MARY POPPINS
LADY THE DISINFORMATION SINGER
SAID SHE HAD INTEGRITY SAID WE
NEEDED GOVERNMENT SPEECH POLICE
IN UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
TURNS OUT SHE BELIEVED THE
HUNTER LAPTOP RUSSIA INFORMATION
AND HE HAD TO YANK HER.
COME ON.
THIS GUY MAYORKAS I KNOW HOW HE
GOT AHEAD BECAUSE I DID A DEEP
DIVE INTO HIS BACKGROUND.
HE IS NOT YOU WHAT THINK HE.
HE GREW UP IN BEVERLY HILLS.
WENT TO GREG'S ALMA MATER
BERKELEY AND HIS WEALTHY FATHER
PLAYED FOR HIM TO GO TO LAW
SCHOOL AND THEN HE PLAYED THE IN
AND OUT WHERE YOU BUILD UP YOUR
NETWORK, YOU BUILD UP YOUR NEST
EGG AND HE WORK THE PATRON AJ
MILL EFFECTIVELY, DIANNE
FEINSTEIN WAS HIS SPONSOR, BILL
CLINTON, JOE BIDEN APPOINTED HIM
AND HE GETS IN THERE AND HE
TOTALLY BLOWS IT BECAUSE HE WAS
AT A HEARING YOU REMEMBER TESTS
CRUZ ASKED HIM AND HE HAS WEEKS
TO PREPARE FOR THE HEARING.
THAT'S ALL THEY DO IS PREPARE
FOR HEARINGS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY PEOPLE THAT
CROSS THE BOARDER?
NO.
DO YOU HAVE KIDS IN CAGES?
DO YOU KNOW IF JOE BIDEN OR
OKLAHOMANS WENT TO THE BORDER?
NO.
HE WAS BORN IN CUBA.
HIS PARENTS WILL BE JEWISH,
WHICH WAS CONFUSING TO ME BUT I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT STUFF.
I'M NOT AS CONFUSED AS HE IS
BECAUSE HE IS VERY, VERY
CONFUSED BUT LYING IDIOTS RISE
TO THE TOP IN WASHINGTON.
>> CAN I ASK A QUESTION?
>> SURE.
>> DON'T WE KNOW THAT JOE BIDEN
DIDN'T KNOW?
>> WHAT DOES THAT MAKE HIM?
>> IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
THAT'SY SAID IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
THEY DON'T WANT TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION BECAUSE OF WHAT THE
ANSWER WOULD BE.
>> WHAT DID HE KNOW AND WHEN DID